こんにちははじめ薩摩です皆さんろエットって知ってますかロケット pict こう
なんかすごい
俺は怖いイメージを持つですよ戦の道具じゃないですかこ日記さが起きるとコンっ
ああああ月らーいやー
みたいな感じの戦における安倍ないものランキング5本の指に入るくらい危険なものだ
と思うんですよロケットってもしそれがですよもしそれがあなたの家に打ち込まれたら
どう思いますか
いやでしょうねそうですいやなんですロケットお家に打ち込まれるなくて皆嫌だと思う
んですけども初めは見えずにパークに御所ロケット打ち込まれることがあるんですけど
もただ実際打ち込まれるとみんなびっくりするんですよと言うけど今日は家にロケット
が内川れると切り足を止めます
まぁちょっとも打ち込めないんですけどね打ち込めないんで今回ですね事前にロケッ
問う突っ込まれたような状況を作りますよでこちら
うどう見てればいいか難しいんですけど
ロケットの先っぽですぐおったんですよロケット打ち込まれるとうち壁暑いんで凸でと
がんですよ壁に刺さって止まるんですよねこの状況この状況を再現しますので壁
いい炎ロケットが先っぽだけぶっ挿しておけばあのゲット去ったんだねーかという見え
方がすると思うんですよ部屋から見るとみてくださいこのでている特注で作って頂き
ました壁ぶち抜いて入ってきたんでちょっと傷ついてる感じがちゃんと出てますね
切符ももう完全にこれ触ってたら絶対ロケットでしょうどう見ても
という感じのこのロケットな席一方壁にぶち込みます入口周辺中身にこれ
打つ今度いてあげてが昇ってきて家なんか見ると
目の前にロケット寄せ食べる果たしでロケットが刺さっている部屋を見てターゲットは
何を思って何を喋るのか見ていこうと思いますではロケットを壁に打ち込んでいき
ましょう
あっあっ
[音楽]
voodoo 数
うんはーい
はいそういうわけでですね今2だロケットが刺さっていてもあれなんで壁に上がっぽい
のお味噌に作っていただいておりますロケット
ぶっ刺さるとか目が奪われるんでこの穴へと呼ばれてる感をここには出さしてもらって
ますと言われたここに俺をさせて完成でございますしばしお待ちを
どうぞよろしくお願いました
おおおおおおおおおお
ありがとうございますた教書さんにお手伝いして頂き取り付けていただきました
こっちで2
バッハ
あーやばいばディティールかっこいいですよ
本当にまずでロケット物産あったらこんな感じなんですよねスゴイのがただ壁が出来
てるじゃなくてこうさっ
亀がバーってだったところまでちゃんと再現されている証拠
すごいです気がこの日で本当にすごい
今から仕掛けていくわけなんですけれどもヘッド目線各すると何もいいですか
てえっ
うーん予定というわけで私のいわき方面でもありなのでちょっとありそうでないような
霧 g ラインをせめて家に入ってきたらミサイルが刺さっている時量をやっていこう
と思います早速
ターゲット左手行きたいと思いますではいきますよ
バーン
ちょっと5し定期的で打って聴いてたい家具
ブーブーえはいはいえっ
ben 10
ただ強くは確認の get lost
ずっと当たると聞いですよあいいじゃんむしろビビるんだねちゃんと
開けてみないと思うちょっと言えなかったけど今度
ビネガーわかりましたでは次のターゲットに行ってみましょう
電源者以外ぴゅっはい始めただけすっ
うわぁえーすごい
ちょっと時間あるなぁここしか見てないからここえーっ
れっし嘉手納のなここもというわけで誰かなロケットが飛び出るドッキリでしたあどう
でしたすごくれません
う技
あるぞやばい記述たいタイプでは大敗
だけうわあああああああ
ああああああ
よろしかっ
ブーバーして r ですねそろそろさんっで
第二言語別といいいい
by つでいいたいに性やその金融時代ん
[音楽]
このモンコレ
シールこれん
me
うううう
ni
car
ame あった
分かっていればできるだけなはずですねあれっ
そうですね
どうぞやって大丈夫かはいちょっと緊急事態に出しが見えます
俺ます
プラーそれッはっはっは